[Music]
PETA has praised Disney's new movie The
Jungle Book for using only CGI animals
but once you see how your
computer-generated animals are made
you'll understand why millions have
stopped watching
we are Pete ASP People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals
specifically people this undercover
video shows the standard methods used to
harvest cgi animals here we see visual
effects workers crammed into tiny cells
forced to eat and sleep in their own
filth some apparently have some feet
from a lack of movement and poor diet
they cannot even support their own
weight and if they fall behind they will
be forced to perform even more degrading
tasks just to survive but the toilet
seat of people doesn't stop there in
order to interact with these CGI animals
this small child was doused with water
ordered to tumble down a fill of mud
again and again
terrorized by a large man and made to
watch this humiliation on film all while
being forced to wear a brown diaper
humans because these visual artists are
never home others in their life must
also suffer perhaps most insulting for
many wild animals being cast in the
jungle book would have been a dream come
true
Cecil the lion waited and waited to hear
from his agent but the cold
brought to you by People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals specifically people
and the producers of babe and babe
taking the city available on Netflix and
Apple TV
[Applause]
you